thank you
[Music]
my name is Elias I come from south of
Paris and I need English because the
next year I went to the in England to CG
international business
[Music]
here at British Council I did a lot of
course with my class so at first I like
my class because I can choose when I
won't do the different course if I want
to do the morning afternoon on events
nights I can choose the different
teachers the topic and it's very good
because you can improve your speaking
your listening and what you want
I think I did a lot of progress in one
month I start A2 and now I I'm B2 and I
can understand everything during the
class because every day I did three
hours the morning and four hours with
intensive course at British concern the
afternoon
I think you have to live like an English
pupil you can sing in English
if if you want to to improve your
English you have to do a lot of course
you have to practice your speaking to be
more fluent I did a lot of things to
improve my English the night I watched a
lot of English series movies during my
previous transport I heard a lot of
English podcasts
obviously because with British Council I
became B2 in one month who is my future
School in England I need P2 and at first
it was impossible for me but with
British console I succeed it in my home
I watch a lot of video in English but
with British console I improve my
pronunciation my speaking I'm more
fluent and I can more understand some
people in English
now I feel better because the last week
there is an Italian people in my class
and she doesn't speak French
so with my English I can understand her
and we can speak in English and now I
think with my future strategies
the English is very important because it
is it's an international language so I
can speak with everyone and it's very
important I think
foreign
[Music]